Christopher Ray was in Congress
yesterday not answering any questions
everything from you know January 6 to
rush everything was it's still on
Investigation they're asking about
Hunter they're asking him about uh Joe
Biden everything there's no answers ever
Charlie so let's say Trump does win
because I think he's going to get the
nomination let's say he wins the
presidency the doj FBI we had to talk
about this on one podcast Pat from what
I would say 95 left Democrat like what
are they going to do like does he even
once he's in Charlie are we gonna have
to deal with all this crap over again
like he's making promises so there's
there's a thing called schedule F where
you're allowed if you sign schedule F as
president you could just fire any
executive branch employee at will now
trump it because of how they're treating
him if by some miraculous intervention
he's able to actually become president
again yeah you are going to see one of
the most motivated Executives to reform
the Leviathan you're fired you're fine
oh I mean but it's going to be a
bloodbath now you say well why didn't he
do that in the first term he wanted to
but he was really handcuffed by a lot of
doubles talk and misleading people that
say we don't do that around here you
know that's not how it works but you
must understand also the context from
the moment Donald Trump took pres the
presidency Peter struck stroke smirk was
in the White House entrapped Lieutenant
General Michael Flynn he was under the
Mueller stuff under the Russia stuff
that Chuck Schumer in January of 2017
before Donald Trump became president Sat
On The Rachel Maddow program said this
the Central Intelligence Agency has six
ways to Sunday of getting back at you
and for supposedly a very shrewd
businessman you're not being very smart
to go after the Intel agencies so they
they set his his first term up and here
he is he doesn't even know where the pen
drawer is in the Resolute desk and he's
dealing with impeachment inquiries and
Mueller stuff and Paul Ryan's against
him so a second term in some ways you
know there's only been one president
that has served you know non-consecutive
terms Grover Cleveland and so he almost
has this breather to come in with like a
fire-breathing mandate which he speak
he's not just like alluding to it he's
being as blunt as blunt can be in his
policy speeches and his rallies of what
he plans to do and look going after the
administrative State again I will repeat
is the existential threat to our Liberty
the promise of the American founding is
representative three branch government
not unrepresentative Shadow Leviathan
fourth Branch bureaucracies running her
life so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
thank you